we turn now to the si.com college
football analyst and a sideline reporter
for fox's college football coverage
fresh back from the Ohio State beat down
of Michigan State 38 to 3 the final
score there Bruce Feldman good to see
you
good to be here so let's start let's
start there where did that Ohio State
team
where was that Ohio State team against
Iowa they clearly were not focused on
this same level I mean when we talked to
Greg Schiano especially the day before
their defense coordinator he was like
it's a very angry Bunch they knew they
had a lot to play for still and they
were unprepared they were unprepared for
Iowa and I think they had a real chip on
the shoulder they they completely shut
down at Michigan State's really young
and it's the first time in a while where
they looked really young Brian lower key
we had them the week before against Penn
State looked terrific in bad conditions
and they just they got punched in the
mouth a couple times and they just
didn't have any answers so Ohio State
looking as good as it looks
Penn State after falling down six
nothing to Rutgers score the final 35 to
look like that so all eyes on Wisconsin
correct this week tis in the Big Ten
community to see if they can beat
Michigan and move forward to the Big Ten
championship game and it makes him hang
yeah they're well coached we had them
earlier in the year it's hard to get a
read on just how good they are because
they don't really played anybody their
best win was just over Iowa completely
shut them down this is obviously a
bigger test because Michigan has some
real real studs on their defense
especially we'll see how Brandon Peters
can play but I think this is a really
good Wisconsin team they're really sound
on on defense they got good defensive
backs what I really like about him is
Jonathan Taylor their freshman running
back in a new jersey and it's the kid
who almost went to Harvard great kid
big has more speed than most of the
Wisconsin running backs we've seen not
like Michael Bennett maybe but some of
these other guys who can who are more
physical backs he can go the distance I
want to see what he's going to be able
to do against Don Browns defense this
weakness so then let's turn our
attention to the ACC here because the
Miami just absolutely grabbed Notre Dame
bottle the Pels and threw him down and
then just beat him up
how good is Miami did we just see how
good Miami could possibly be in your
mind you know that was the best
performance by far they've had all year
because you
they're undefeated a little bit like
Wisconsin until last weekend where they
hadn't really been tested
they played FSU who's a shell of itself
without their starting quarterback and
they're falling apart and they needed a
last-second when to pull that one all
right
they played a awful North Carolina team
a couple of weeks ago and North
Carolina's like one in eight they barely
beat North Carolina but last week
Virginia Tech came in there and they
stomped them pretty good and then this
weekend I think what they had was Miami
has some really good athletes on defense
by the way our old colleague from Oregon
spent days many Diaz I don't if you
remember him Manny is Miami's defensive
coordinator he's done a terrific job
there I mean just they are really
aggressive they're really good up front
they're really athletic
I think the defense is probably two
steps ahead of where Miami's offense
needs to be Miami's has some skill
talent but it just doesn't have the same
depth but this whole you know the
turnover chain has gotten a lot of
attention but it what you have is a team
that is playing with such a chip on its
shoulder and I think a lot of people
said am Notre Dame's gonna come in there
and they're gonna steamroll you because
you're just not tough enough and that
was a challenge that the whole community
they're basically seem like they took
upon and they'd you know the one of the
Notre Dame coaches kind of called out
the program it got back and you know
right before the game Miami responded I
don't know if they are I think they're a
they're probably a year away from being
a a legit national title contender but
they may be they may be on track the way
they're playing their offense has been a
pleasant surprise in their defense is
pretty nasty and Alabama just proved its
mettle once again I mean that that win
in Starkville was really impressive that
was a spot where it looked from the jump
one of those games on the road in the
SEC at night crowd going crazy that they
were that that was a night that they
were gonna get gone and they didn't they
they won that game in impressive fashion
coming back to win that game how in the
world are they not give me give me give
me give me the the team that knocks them
off that is the best chance to beat them
over isn't playing really well right now
I mean Auburn played a Georgia team that
has a lot of talent especially on
defense and and Auburn just mauled them
carry on Johnston's are running back now
who he was for a second about the
Heisman its Baker Mayfield to lose and
it talked about all these other running
this year say Quan Berkeley he's
fantastic but he is tailed off Bryce
love from Stanford has a really
remarkable season you know even Josh
shadows from Notre Dame all of a sudden
now carry on Johnson who ran all over a
Georgia defense that is loaded with NFL
talent and they blew them out if he does
something similar against Alabama's
defense which by the way is really
banged up they're down four linebackers
a couple of weeks ago LSU starting to
true freshman offensive lineman they ran
the ball really well against Alabama I
think Alabama's definitely vulnerable I
just don't know if all burn which has
been pretty wildly inconsistent if they
can be if they can respond well to this
success and everybody now fired up about
them they have a chance I think to knock
off Alabama so okay so we've got Bruce
Feldman here on this edition of the Rich
Eisen show Oklahoma plays Kansas so
let's just let's give them another win
there they're 10 and 1 and then then
comes the big 12 championship game of
the first time or they yeah they have
another game they have another game but
then so and then they take on Oklahoma
State again is that are they gonna take
on we'll see how this shakes out I mean
because what you have now it's kind of a
mess in the big 12 but Oklahoma to me
now people gonna look and go oh well
they lost the Iowa State Iowa State's
actually pretty good they were in the
top 20 before they beat TCU also so you
look at what Oklahoma as they have that
nobody has a better trio of wins on the
resume then Oklahoma then Oklahoma does
they they really thumped Ohio State in
Columbus that was impressive they beat
Oklahoma State at Oklahoma State their
archrival
and then this weekend beat a really good
team people look at them and go yeah
their defense is not very good and you
know whatever bad Baker Mayfield right
now Baker Mayfield is the big second
yeah the best player in college football
and he has plays with so much confidence
where he'd be a hard guy to bet against
I'm not sure if Oklahoma played anybody
at this point the way Baker Mayfield
playing I wouldn't say you know what
nobody is that much better than Oklahoma
he does look like the type of guy who
would give Alabama fits right I mean it
gives anybody fits but I mean you take a
look at what deshaun Watson looked like
the last two years
Mayfield could present a similar issue
for Alabama the question is is how this
Final Four is gonna shake up and in a
few minutes I have left with you I let's
start supposing
I guess so Wisconsin Michigan's a big
game then the ACC championship game
barring anything unforeseen between
Miami and Clemson to get there that's a
huge game right yeah any chance that
Alabama loses the Iron Bowl and then
pulls in Ohio State by that I mean they
don't even play in the SEC championship
game
Auburn and Georgia play each other and
then the final four sits down and
they're like okay look
Auburn's terrific tough spot throw the
records out in the Iron Bowl Alabama's
Alabama we want everybody sitting down
on the TV set and and watch one that
some of these games unlike the last
couple years we took a little bit of a
bath on the ratings because if it was
Christmas New Year's Eve etc right that
they keep Alabama out or just say we got
to put them in there I think there I
definitely think there's a chance of
that now what's what you said a second
ago was Alabama's Alabama nobody getting
the benefit of the doubt like Alabama
does because if you look at the resume
of what they done it's not loaded with
great wins they have their best win was
what they had this past weekend at
Mississippi State no by the way
Mississippi State was blown off the
field by Georgia you know also this
season it's not like Mississippi State
is a top five team but well they had it
together on Saturday night they
absolutely did they did but LSU gave
them a hard game the week before that
you know now out gain them and
everything so I think when you look at
their resume they have their two best
wins are Mississippi State and LSU if
they lose to Auburn it's not like
they're gonna have a great resume they'd
be 11 and 1 that Florida State win that
doesn't mean anything Florida State
maybe is gonna be lucky to get to a bowl
game so you know Texas A&M they beat
them on the road it was a close game
Texas A&M is a barely above you know
barely above 500 so the resume itself is
not that great but I think the benefit
of the doubt that they've had for being
so good for so long yes I think that may
carry them through depending on how some
of these other things pile because
they're one loss scene you could get if
Ohio State looks the way they did in our
game against Michigan State does that
you know I think they'll crush Illinois
but then gets Michigan and then if they
beat an undefeated or even a 1 loss
Wisconsin team handily
I think Ohio State despite getting blown
out by an unranked Iowa team I think
Ohio State has a pretty good chance I'm
making the playoff with two losses
look I think we'll what happened this
weekend is the pac-12 just relinquished
their seat at the table there
yeah so Friday night was when Washington
lost I think that was right exactly so
they relinquished their seat at the
table here so the big 12 winner the big
10 winner the ACC winner and the SEC
winner they go unless somehow someway
Auburn beats Alabama and a close game
whoever wins that game in the SEC
championship game gets a spot and then
Alabama at one loss gets in him above
let's say Wisconsin losing once before
getting in or before getting into the
Big Ten Champion game in beats Ohio
State or Ohio State wins out with two it
could come down to Ohio State winning
out they beat that school up north
mm-hmm as I've tried to be respectful
and then beats an undefeated Wisconsin
in the Big Ten championship game could
it possibly come down to a two loss Ohio
State game under the team under that
situation and then ignore Bama that's it
on the outside looking in or Auburn on
the outside looking in
yeah and they wouldn't do that though I
don't know Barbour has those wins down
the stretch how other plan
I think I burned two losses they lost
relatively close to Clemson and then
they they lost because they were really
dreadful in the second half at LSU but I
think you know by the way just to clear
up the ratings point I think the ratings
point is an interesting one if it's Ohio
State versus Alabama
you know the committee can't lose there
because they both are huge huge TV draws
so I wouldn't you know get caught up on
that part of it in this case but you
know it's like how well you're playing
at the end I mean one team didn't win
its conference doesn't have great wins
and that's being Alabama they only have
one loss whereas your Ohio State you
blown blown out twice once at home once
by an unranked team I'm curious how the
committee would sort that out okay and
the 90 seconds I have left with you here
Bruce Feldman um
Chip Kelly to Florida real not real what
do you got for me on there I think
there's a chance I think Florida has
real interest in him they've been
terrible on offense the last decade to
me he's the most innovative best
offensive mind
in football and Chip Kelly and the FCC
would be phenomenal he would be the only
thing and Florida doesn't have this as
much as Tennessee Tennessee has this
really fishbowl quality of it that if
you're the head coach there you got to
deal with a lot of stuff and a lot of
guys don't want to deal with that I only
chip kelly would want to deal with
at Florida you don't have as much of
that but the thing is Chip Kelly could
load up on talent in that state I mean
in South Florida
yes Florida in northern Florida all over
the place I think what he has to
consider is if I pass on Florida if I
could get Florida I don't take it then
where am I going to end up am I gonna
get to be the Nebraska guy is UCLA gonna
gonna spend a lot of money to get rid of
Jim Mora is Arizona State come open you
don't know what's gonna happen with
Arizona State or you see Texas A&M I
don't think chips are fit there I I mean
or is someone gonna lose his job I think
I think Kevin someone's you know the ad
there Scott Woodward made it clear he
wants a change and I think that's gonna
be a change but a big positive for chip
that I think a lot of people overlook is
you could get him at a cut rate because
the NFL is paying him a lot of money
with the Niners so he is a bargain and
if I'm somebody else I'm like man and
I'm in that conference I don't want Chip
Kelly coming in there I mean Chip
Kelly's a great offensive coach he's a
very innovative and I think kids would
he'd be a lot easier form to recruits
one of these programs than it is in
Eugene Oregon good to see you thanks for
coming in always play development here
on the riches and show Mark Ingram of
the Saints when we come back the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience